are you scared to do it cuz your parents
won't like it no my parents actually
support me okay so when you scared of
failing not failing that still being at
the same place when my friends are the
next level huge mistake
you don't want the same thing your
friends want so why the [ __ ] do you care
what they have the biggest reason people
are unhappy right now is because they
value somebody else's opinion more than
they value their own have the
conversation with the person that's
holding you back the reason most people
who are listening right now we're not
doing that thing is they're worried
about the opinion of somebody on
somebody's I am so devastated that you
actually let your grandma's point of
view your mom your dad your sister your
aunt you still let somebody else dictate
based on their opinion every action you
do and it's your life
the reason I'm super happy is nobody can
tell me nothing
my wife mom and daughter could walk into
my room right now tell me on a piece of
crap and I would be 100% unfazed that is
some gangster emotional structure
if you're not feeling it find new
friends I'm being dead serious about
this this one is real big for me the
only way I've seen now that I'm older
that you can build confidence is if you
surround yourself with people that are
optimistic start trimming your friend
group and start adding to your friend
group predicated on what you want to be
like it's unbelievable what happened to
me when I got into the Silicon Valley
world and started meeting like Mark
Zuckerberg and like F Williams and
socket and like Travis like it changed
my life
everybody in this room needs to cut out
as much of the noise and time with
people that are negative and spend as
much time with people that are positive
the people you spend time with are the
ones that dictate your mindset you can
limit your time with your mom you can
limit your time with your best friend
you could tell your girlfriend or
husband to go [ __ ] themselves
yeah you [ __ ] roll up in your dad
your mom your sister and say [ __ ] you
I'm out because you're [ __ ] toxic
I'll see you in six years you can figure
out why the [ __ ] I left you're accepting
to be in that relationship
if you feel motivated by this
conversation or you're intrigued by it
add one new winner friend like you know
what I mean
I had one new winner friend and cut one
loser friend I felt like even when I
give it away and I don't speak to them
the chatter of them talk like that means
it's like that means you value their
opinions yeah I don't yeah
please let this be the video that drills
through your head that your life is
predicated on when you get real quiet
and you can't hear another [ __ ]
person's two cents that has nothing to
do with you and everything to do with
where there are in life are you really
gonna let those eight or nine people
dictate your life because you are so
fearful of judgment from others that at
the end of the day when you're 87 you
will not give a [ __ ] about
you